this episode is sponsored by blinkist
blinkist puts all the need to know
information from thousands of
non-fiction books
and condenses them down into just 15
minutes
and you can go to blinkist.com
microcosmos to learn more
[Music]
hi it's me debokey back on the cnidarian
beat
last time i was here we explored the
terrifying world of anhydrous tentacles
today i'm here to talk about one of
their relatives
the starlet sea anemone also known as
the matastella victenzis
i didn't know that i've spent my entire
life
mispronouncing anemone as an enemy
until i began learning about the starlet
c anemone
and so i will often be referring to them
as nomadistella
throughout this episode i hope you
understand
i can't fault the starlet c anemone for
its name though
after all i have a name that often
involves correcting
others pronunciation and there's more to
the nevada stella's life that i feel
kinship with
but to get there i need to start with a
question
when you look at the starlet sea anemone
where do you think it's from the water
sure but water is vast
vaster than land and it has its own
boundaries and geography
so like where do you think it's really
from
we can tell you where this particular
individual is from
a lab at the university of vienna where
it lived
until a scientist named sanjay sent one
of his samples to james
our master of microscopes so that he
and we could look at them so thank you
sanjay
there are a lot of nematostelas in labs
around the world
their bodies and reproduction are simple
providing us with the means to explore
the questions and secrets
behind how patterns and layers form in
bodies across
nature but before the nomadistella ended
up in labs
they or one of their forebears must have
come
from somewhere but where
the answer should be simple in 1935
the biologist thomas alan stevenson
gathered
20 years worth of work into a two-volume
monograph
titled the british sea anemones
in there lies the first recorded
description of the starlet sea anemone
which had been found in a brackish pond
on the isle of wight
[Music]
compared to the organisms we usually
focus on
the nematostela is quite large growing
several millimeters in height
but for someone wading through a pond
it'd be easy to overlook
it's small translucent in a burrower
digging itself into mud and letting its
tentacles spill out onto the visible
surface
but difficult as the nomadistella is to
spot
researchers became concerned in the
1980s
when their counts of the starlet sea
anemone in england began to dwindle
in 1983 the nematostelo was classified
as a vulnerable species
to protect it from extinction this is
sadly
not an uncommon tale when it comes to
our interactions with wildlife
and so it's tempting to leave it here
to allow the starlet sea anemone to
become yet another cautionary tale
of our environmental misdeeds
and yet while the species was first
described in britain
it has been found in other parts of the
world too
particularly on both the atlantic and
pacific coasts of north america
and when scientists counted there seemed
to be
plenty of pneumatistella in these other
regions
but there were some weird quirks to
these different populations
the english nomadistella population
seemed to be completely void of males
like an underwater themiskira
meanwhile the population in nova scotia
seemed to be
entirely male and there didn't seem to
be
any environmental explanation for why
some populations might be different from
the others
so what caused these pneumatistella to
take up
at such different locations and in
such different ways boats
[Music]
for centuries boats have been traveling
the world
taking cargo and passengers alike and
with them have traveled
even smaller passengers including most
likely
the nematta stella after all it's small
and hearty able to survive journeys
through the different temperatures and
salinities
and most importantly for the traveling
the matastella
it can reproduce asexually dividing to
form more
versions of itself this would explain
why we might find populations of the
starlet sea anemone
that are entirely female or entirely
male
that's just the one that showed up first
the one that made its way to a new home
and then
filled it with its own clones
our genes are a map of our ancestors
lives
and in the case of the nomadistella
they've helped scientists chart the path
the organism likely took
the neumatistela in britain for example
have very little genetic diversity
compared to their new england
counterparts suggesting that the british
ones
are a more recent transplant in using
inferences like that scientists have
pieced together a story
where nematostela made its way from the
western atlantic
or maybe less confusingly the east coast
of north america
and then traveled the world from there
so the nomadistella is not native to
britain
it's a recent arrival early informing
its identity
but when it comes to asking where the
starlet sea anemone is from
i'll be straightforward it's hard not to
project a little
as someone who has been asked that
question in its many forms before
and as someone whose home is an
amalgamation
of the immediate places i've lived in
and
a city on the other side of the world
where i didn't
even learning about how the genetic
uniformity of certain populations
provides us snapshots of the anemone's
journey
feels familiar immigration and diasporas
are
complex and nuanced so there's no way to
generalize from my own experience
but an idea that i heard once and that
has stuck with me
when i understand my indian american
experience
is this notion that first and second
generations like me
tend to carry our family's country of
origin with us
from a certain point of time so that the
traditions and rituals we choose to
maintain in this new home
tie us together while also inevitably
dating us
often when you're a first or second
generation immigrant in america
your journey is framed in terms of
tension
of a tension between who claims you and
who you claim
i hate thinking in these terms even when
it feels true
because i've come to realize that as
much as these claims
are impactful they can also be arbitrary
shifting with the currents and climate
and location
if it's a question of where i belong the
answer will always be conditional
and that's frustrating defining the
nematostela's origins is conditional as
well
dependent upon the asker's aims
but the nomadistella is not an immigrant
and i have no desire to compare the
entirety of the immigrant experience
and its human realities to an anemone
as a question of conservation though
then mata stella's origins
become significant in england
where our understanding of the species
originated
the populations are dwindling but
the efforts to protect it are built more
on
earlier assumptions that the
nomadistella is a native species
which we know now it is not
but we also know that whenever the
nematostela
arrived at its new home it took to it
and without causing further harm to its
local ecology
in the early 2000s scientists argued
that
while we may not need to introduce
populations of nematella to its british
locations
it is still worth protecting the ones
that are already there
so where is the nematode from
well it depends and this time
i find that kind of beautiful
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us
and we'd like to thank blinkist for
sponsoring today's episode
these days it can be hard to remember
that your phone can be used for
productive purposes
it's extremely easy to find yourself
scrolling in one app
only to close that one and start
scrolling in another
and suddenly without even noticing it
you find that you're back in that first
app again
how did that happen well blinkist is
here to help you use your time more
effectively
blinkist is an app that takes the best
insights and need to know information
from over 3 000 nonfiction books and
condenses them down
into just 15 minutes that you can read
or
listen to it can be hard to find the
time to sit down
and learn more but with blinkist you can
explore their massive library of books
in categories like self-help business
science
and history we're often showing you
microbes that look like tiny specks on
your screen
but once you check out carl sagan's
cosmos on blinkist
and try to wrap your head around how big
the universe that we live in
actually is you'll start to look at our
planet as if it is just a
tiny speck within another tiny speck and
if you're one of the first hundred
people to sign up today at blinkist.com
microcosmos
you can get free unlimited access for
seven days
and you'll also get 25 off if you decide
to get a full membership
click the link in the description to
start your free seven-day trial
the names on the screen those are our
patreon patrons
and we'd like to thank each and every
one of you who has chosen to support
this channel
and if you'd like to become one of those
people you can go to patreon.com
journey2micro if you want to see more
from
our master of microscopes james weiss
you can check out jm and germs on
instagram
or also on tiktok and if you want to see
more from
us there's always a subscribe button
somewhere
[Music]
nearby
you